[Music]
hello dear friends what a blessing it is
for us to enjoy this program with you in
a program where we can answer your
questions interact with your inquiries
and we thank you for sending them to us
we Delight to hear from you and to
receive the questions the many questions
that we have each week and uh I have the
privilege today to have Pastor Daniel
Miranda with me Pastor welcome to the to
this program it's a blessing to have you
here yes absolutely thank you for the
invitation I love being part of this
program amen and we enjoy your company
we enjoy your comments and the Insight
that the Lord has given you and before
we start we want to invite you once
again to send your questions to the
following address which is
TVs
tv.org
TV do Sam tv.org I pray that you will be
blessed by this study of the scriptures
and as we open today's study and and
questions Pastor let us have a word of
prayer so can you please pray for us
absolutely let's pray heavenly father as
we open your word we pray that your Holy
Spirit May guide us into the questions
that we have for today we do not claim
to have all the wisdom the true wisdom
comes from you amen so please impress
Upon Our Hearts the right answers and
also help those who are listening to
this program to discern the truth we
pray all these things in the name of
Jesus amen amen thank you Pastor and now
we have a question that comes to us from
Eugene that uh and he's in Bahamas and
we thank Eugene for sending the question
and for his uh you know for for being a
viewer of our program and the question
is this an interesting question he has
and it says why didn't the sons and
grandsons of matusa not make it on the
ark when they assisted in the building
of the Ark this is the question he has
and you may ask yourselves or you know
or viewers might be thinking why is he
asking that question well there is a
reason and he actually puts the quote
see the quote below he says this is
found in volume three of spiritual gifts
page 59 and it says the following
Methuselah and his sons and grandsons
lived in the time of the building of the
Ark they with some others received
instructions from Noah and assisted him
in building the ark so we can see from
the spirit of Prophecy from this quote
that Noah was assisted by Methuselah his
sons and Grands sons in the building of
the Ark and so the question natural
question is why didn't they make it into
the ark why are they not mentioned as
you know coming into the ark and the
Bible is clearly in defining that only
eight people were saved Noah his wife
his three sons and his three
daughters-in-law so we have to ask the
question and or answer this question
which is a very interesting question
Pastor what can we say about this
question you know one of the things I
love about this program is that you get
questions that you've never asked
yourself before yes yes and this is one
of those right this really this really
strengthens your research amen uh
questions you know this is a very in
interesting very interesting
question I mean the Bible is not clear
about that the Bible is clear about what
you just said there is enough biblical
evidence that only eight Souls were
saved we find that in Hebrews um chapter
11 we find that in Genesis chapter 6
chapter 7 actually chapter 7 chapter 8
and chapter 9 so the Bible is very clear
on that now of course
Methuselah he died before the flood mhm
now why his sons and grandsons who
assisted
Noah yes um in building the ark why they
didn't make it so for me there is only
one possibility actually there can be
two possibilities but I'm inclined to
believe in one one possibility which is
the least likely is that they died
before the flood MH but that's still a
possibility but why do I think is the
least likely because we find the
genealogies of Genesis
chapter um you know
five and later the other genealogies of
the sons of Noah we find that these
people lived long enough yes and they
were very I mean they they they had
longevity
now um it is only until the time of
[Music]
Abraham's father or or grandfather that
we find that a son dies before their
father okay now the other possibility
that I'm inclined to believe is that
they for some time they believe they
receive the instruction the the sons and
grandsons of Methuselah but later they
went back and rejected the light why do
I say this is more probable because in
the book Patriarchs and Prophets Ling
why says that some people actually ateed
Noah in in the construction of the Ark
but then they were influenced by the
mockers and they eventually ended up
disbelieving that this was actually true
I mean time was going by and nothing was
happening so that could be for me a
possibility yes they receive the light
they receive the instruction they even
help and and it is not crazy to think
that because today we see it all the
time people who have embraced the truth
they have been active in the church and
for some reason they leave the church so
even children and grandchildren of great
leaders uh in the church so no one is
exempt from that amen Pastor I think you
have answered the question quite well I
could just add to what you said
something interesting you know just
looking at we we know that the name
matus
has a special meaning uh matusa was of
course the grandparent the grandfather
of Noah right Noah whose father was
lamech was the son of the firstborn of
matusa and matusa his name if if we look
at the at the compound word because this
is actually two words in the Hebrew it
it has a meaning the man of a of a spear
or if you actually go deeper into that
it it means when he is dead he shall be
sent so when he was to die the flood
would be sent now interestingly enough
matusa who lived the longest of all the
living you know humans that we know in
history on this Earth he died at the
year uh at the age of 969 years this why
he's the oldest man alive
now his son lamech who was the father of
Noah he lived a a s 777 years he died at
the at the time when his father still
outlive him by 82 years so methus
actually was outlived his own son lamech
his own son which was the father of Noah
he outlived um his son by 82 years or
I'm sorry not 82 years I'm I'm mistaken
by five years rather mhm
this is how it goes he was uh matus was
was the father of lamech lamech was born
and after he was born matusa lived for
782 extra years and matus Salah and
lamech only live 777 years so he
outlived his son for five years that is
an interesting and so with that in mind
uh lamech we can actually answer the
first part you know lamech who maybe was
a man of God he died m one of his sons
yes one his sons so he died now his
other grandsons besides Noah the
brothers of Noah or the cousins of Noah
as you mentioned the Bible doesn't say
anything else but the likely scenario is
that if they were
alive when the flood came they either
rejected God or rejected the truth and
they turned away from the truth as you
have mentioned so eloquently or the
other explanation is they die before
just prior to whether it was because of
disease sickness or because of the
violence on the earth remember there was
a lot of violence a lot of evil so maybe
God granted them the the opportunity to
die or or they die because of the
violence in the world either way the
Bible doesn't tell us necessarily what
happened but as you mentioned El white
does mention that there were many who
believed and even were convicted but
after a while they turn away yeah right
and and we see that happening in our
time as well yeah there is this is a
very very good point about lamech um and
you know the comparison of Ages and and
he was one of methusa sons and he had
other Sons it seems that he perhaps was
the oldest one usually the oldest ones
are mentioned in the
genealogies um so so some like lamech is
clear he died before the flood uh what
happened to the rest because he says
here sons and grandsons yeah well some
of his grandsons Noah was a grandson but
um the other ones the other ones Noah's
siblings yeah you what happened to them
we don't know exactly so the only
explanation we say is is perhaps this
there's no clear evidence right but we
at least can give you the answer to
lamech who died before the flood and the
year of the flood was the year that
matus died great question yes a great
question so interesting Pastor can you
read the next question for us of course
yeah this comes from Fortune C and no
location is given but uh he says he's
from here in his question he actually
tells oh actually he does yeah Zimbabwe
thank you Zimbabwe hi Pastor bore this
is Fortune from Zimbabwe my first
question is based on Malachi 4
ver5 is Elijah going to come that's his
first question the second question is
based on Genesis
2:7 what is the nature of God's breath
is it power or something
else interesting question good question
from our friend fortune and so well let
me briefly try to give a an answer to
the first part of the question he's
asking is Elijah going to come well
let's go first to the verse of Malachi
that he's talking about and he is uh
quoting what is said at the very end of
the Book of Malachi is the actual uh
last two verses of the of the verse that
tells us you know this concept now it
says here behold I will send you elah
the prophet before the coming of the
great and Dreadful day of the Lord now
verse six is sort of gives us the reason
yeah what he's sending Elijah the
prophet and he shall turn the heart of
the fathers to the children and the
hearts of the children to their fathers
lest I come and smite the Earth with a
curse so here we have
a prophecy or a promise of God that
before the last and Dreadful day of the
Lord God will send Elijah to do a a work
of
restoration of bringing back families
parents and children turning their
hearts to one another that Harmony of
course is in the word of God is the
harmony of parents and children
realizing their need of the Savior the
need of Christ and coming together
because of the word of God now is Elijah
physically going to come well I'll
answer the question I think it's it's
probably better to to answer the
question based on what Jesus spoke of
the um the the the Prophet Elijah coming
in his time you know uh in his time
there was a man who Christ said it was
Elijah that came and um and I and I
think um I I I can actually guide that
it believes in the book of uh Luke if
I'm not
mistaken and it's it tells us there that
Jesus when he was speaking of of who
Elijah was or who I'm sorry John the
Baptist was he mentioned to them and
Elijah indeed come I don't know if you
have that verse Pastor because I'm I'm
there is one in Matthew 17 verse 11 I
don't know if that's the one you're
looking but it also mentions that which
actually is in the context of the
Transfiguration where we see Elijah and
then the disciples are um are perplexed
when they see the vision and then verse
10 it says his disciples asked him
saying why then do the scribes say that
Elijah must come first Jesus answered
and said to them indeed Elijah is coming
first and will restore or all things and
then verse 12 and 13 Say by say unto you
that Elijah has come already and they
did not know him but did to him whatever
they wish likewise the son of man is
also about to suffer at their hands then
the disciples understood that he spoke
to them of John the Baptist very good
thank you Pastor that's that's that's a
very clear uh explanation there so we
see that Jesus explains to them that
Elijah had already come and is not
necessarily the person itself but
speaking of the spirit of Elijah the
message and the and the and the work of
Elijah through John the Baptist so if
Christ mentioned Elijah that he already
had come he was again and the disciples
clearly understood that he was speaking
about John the Baptist we know that this
Prophet or this uh promise or prophecy
of Elijah coming in the end at the end
of time before the day great day of the
Lord is not speaking of physically a
prophet named Elijah or the Elijah the
prophet coming from Heaven back down
it's speaking of the spirit and the
power of Elijah of the message of Elijah
to bring serration to the EXA to the
families yeah this is a great example
because if if Jesus was thinking of
little Elijah he would have made
reference to the Elijah of the Mount of
transfiguration exactly that the
disciples had just seen But in instead
he made reference to John the Baptist
perfect now Pastor what can you tells us
about the second question the question
based on Genesis 2 verse 7 about the
breath that
God has and how he you know he blew on
the nostrils of of of of Adam and made
him a living Soul what could we say
about that expression is is is is this
something of a power or something else
as he's
asking so uh let's read um as it says in
Genesis chapter 2 and verse 7 right uh
Genesis 2 and verse 7 and this is what
the Bible says and the Lord God formed
man of the Dust of the ground and
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life and Man became a living being so
the question is what is that breath
breath Nash in the Hebrew what is that
what is it that the Lord breathe into
his n so some people have limited the
Breath of
Life um to Simply the idea or the
ability to breathe now even though that
is included there I believe that there
is more to that yes the Bible uh
constantly uses the concept of the
breath or or the spirit in reference to
life to character moral character
actually right so for example let me
just uh find and give you a few
references uh here
okay
okay so for example when we go to the
books
of um Genesis I they're in the Book of
Genesis
again verse
22 the same concept is used us and it
says all in whose nostrils was the
breath of the spirit of Life all that
was on the dry land died so here is re
referring to human beings and also to
animals okay the all in whose nostrils
was the breath of the spirit of life now
um in other occasions let me
see in this one here Psalm 18 16 for
example Psalm okay
1816 I have it if you want me to read it
yes please he says he sent from above he
took me he drew me out of many
Waters um oh verse 15 rather it says
then the channels of waters were seen
and the foundations of the world were
discovered at thy rebuke oh Lord at the
blast of the breath of thy nostr
so notice that this is more just a mere
breath because it says that when God
speaks at the blast of the breath of
your nostrils it says that the channels
of the sea were seen the foundations of
the world were were
uncover so I I do agree to some extent
with with my brother fortune that the
Breath of God has to do with his power
his power to give life he power to
create because even when God spoke
everything was done with the breath
actually if you read Pastor um Psalm 33:
6 and9 we find that concept of the
Breath of Life which actually also is a
reference to the Holy Spirit he says
there by the word of the Lord were the
heavens made and all the host of them by
the breath of his mouth and verse n for
he spake and he was done he commanded
and he stood fast interesting it says
the word of the Lord and then the the
next part by the breath of his mouth
that is correct you could actually also
for example in job 33 job 33:4 it says
the spirit of God had made me yes and
the breath of the almighty had given me
life so now the breath there is the
spirit of God yes so you see that is a
very we cannot narrow it down to one one
single thing we cannot use just that one
verse to Define what the spirit is um I
believe the spirit has has to do with
with your your spiritual nature that
uh God has wants to give you you know he
gave Adam and Eve at the beginning yeah
uh the breath of life that came into
them was more than just the life it was
the the character the image of God the
same spirit that goes back to God who
gave
that has to do with the with spiritual
nature Ellen y has a a quote where she
says that that um the spirit of a man is
his character she says that so so yes it
is God's power when it comes to Creation
but it is also our moral nature our own
personality um the spirit the Holy
Spirit the work of the holy spirit in
our lives and the Holy Spirit himself is
sometimes used yeah with that
reference to
breath and it's important that we see
this as you mentioned the the way that
God presents us as a as the ability to
have life itself because of that power
and that's why man cannot make life only
God is the author of life as the Bible
has said okay we have probably qu time
for one more question this is from Henry
and it says the following I am told that
it is impossible for anyone to be
sinless in this lifetime and so the
example of Moses Paul and others was
given that this man also died with sins
still intact in his character and yet he
was taken to Heaven I am told that no
one in this life can live a sinless life
and that we will only become sinless
when Christ comes in the cloud of Heaven
what are your thoughts I I think Henry
needs to uh maybe we have a a whole
series on a little bit of on on this
aspect of the nature of man but Pastor
what can we say in this few minutes in
this few minutes yes I actually recently
preached a sermon here on on this
channel um about what is sin yes now if
we understand sin by
Nature then it is obvious to conclude
that no one in this life is sinless
because we will have a sinful human
nature until until Jesus comes 1
Corinthians
15: 15 through 53 tell us clearly that
until Jesus comes we're going to have
something corruptible which is our
nature and Jesus is going to transform
that into
incorruption now Len sometimes uses that
word with that sense but
also being sinless means living a life
of obedience not
necessarily being without any human uh
Fallen nature if that is the sense in
which we look at this then it is
possible to have a sinless life that is
a life of obedience and I believe that
is more in harmony with scripture
because the only definition of sin is
that sin is the transgression of the law
um so living a sinless life means that
I'm living a life that is pleasing to
God in the best of my ability I am
keeping the Commandments of God not by
my own merits but by the grace of Christ
am I going to commit some mistakes every
now and then I certain will sometimes
but God in the ceiling he will just
settle our characters because we have
obeyed that during the time of trouble
as inspiration is very clear that God's
people even though will go through
severe Temptations and and and 144,000
will be tempted to disb believe in the
promises of God but they will not sin
even in their thoughts that's why what
the spirit of Prophecy says so in that
sense they will be sinless but not in
the sense that they will not have a
falling human nature it is important
that we encourage of course you know our
our our viewers and and Henry that we
need to to do some study to understand
you know even farther what this means
this is not that you are going to be
like you mentioned uh in in in in a holy
flesh experience where you are unable to
to no longer be tempted you are going to
have to deal with this infirmities with
this condition of the human nature but
your heart is transformed your heart is
in syntony with God and you by the grace
of God have learned to have a life of
obedience like those men who are
mentioned examples men who were obedient
even to death in you know to the Lord
for being faithful to him so we thank
you for the time we pray that you will
continue to study more of God's word and
we look forward to having you in this PR
in the near future may God bless you
[Music]